he's also very polarizing oh big time
what was it like working with him
because he has a lot of very interesting
opinions yeah a lot of people say he's
kind of like Uncle Ruckus yeah the memes
I've seen the memes man Wheelock is
Whitlock one thing about him you could
say whatever he is about what he
believes and what he says and that's
what I like now that doesn't mean he
lives out all of that I'm saying his
opinion is going to be unwavering unless
challenged by something greater right
and I love that I
I don't care how you get on top of your
mountain man there's so many different
paths I'm not here to judge in that
respect but be you that's what I love
the most about him now what's tough
being with Whitlock is he's always going
to throw some extra hot sauce on no
matter what he says it could be the most
simple of takes
he's gonna put some spikes on it right
and at times I feel that's unnecessary
but that's how he serves it so you gotta
either eat it or you're gonna be mad at
it